mais j ai dit qu on voyait qu'on aborde
également la pas venez de niamey mehdi
et et nicolas c'est très simple vous
allez mettre cette vous allez mettre la
borne est dit ici vous allez mettre
cette main géante
ah ouais d'accord cette main géante et
regardez ici il a de la peinture on va
jouer aux dés en sang vous allez avoir
deux des émois de départ à la main
droite
vous voulez produit ce que vous les
prenez la main droite d'accord gers et
les blâmes à gauche n'a pas coulé sous
les 2 sens tu vas jouer avec monique aux
attentes et n y qu il a pas besoin de
fausse main ça m'allait déjà face à nico
de ses bourreaux a assez alors attention
on va jouer avec dédé asseyez-vous mais
il ya de la peinture ici tu as entre les
doigts
ouais ouais j'suis des douanes mon doigt
est là mais dit après bien sûr
j'affronterai nico et qu'est ce que j'ai
envie de lui mettre cette main dans la
gueule parce que la dernière fois qu'il
est venu il m'a fracassé enfin il m'a
fracassé c'est très simple on va tirer
avec l'edd et celui qui fera le plus
petit chiffre
il ya l'autre prendra la main il la
mettra dans la peinture il lui fera un
tableau de la pièce ça marche 3 vous
pouvez venir vérifier un c3 merci à fait
même d'octroi je te les mets là donc il
faudrait que je fasse deux ouais ouais
donc tu vas pas la rater sur a3 est
inférieure à notre faim
vas-y malin mais du talent bonjour
quelqu'un talbot jour quelqu'un m'a dit
t'as le bonjour à nos attentes à la date
où le jockey tomber adam et je revois
talent talbot jaune dakar
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est parti attention cette ça
passe il faut aller le chercher de 7 ans
par un patron se soustraient sur ma part
je ne le fera pas enfin apparence pas
mal par sa sueur comme son sport voilà
déjà au mieux pas non et 6 si tu fais si
son égalité
je vais commencer à plonger maman quand
même c'est pas ta fait tomber des tabous
nous trois les deux cas c'est fou hein
ouais bah on va s'enfermer ne vous
inquiétez pas
e
[Applaudissements]
je la sens pas du tout six ans la 6e
égaliser légale avec un messi c'est
dégueulasse
[Applaudissements]
je la ferme à gauche à gauche avec le
pousse à l'envers 3 non mais ça
m'arrange pas parce que moi j'ai de ce
truc après je veux redevenir comme avant
non parce que mehdi vois je t'adore
faveur tu as le bon jour de la
[Applaudissements]